So next time,
we're going to to do a we're not going
to give up generative models yet.
We're going to show you a really
cool way of building a sort
of a low dimensional generative model
called Principal Component Analysis.
It was first done not first, but
became popular when done for
face recognition, and
that's a form of a general model.
But more important, you'll just
learn about principle components.
Which is used a lot in computer vision,
and for all sorts of things.
And after we do that,
we're going to move to this other set
of methods which are discriminative.
Where instead of modeling the,
the, categories themselves,
instead we learn about the boundaries
between the categories.
And that we'll continue to do as
we talk more about recognition.